Speaker 1: In Pennsylvania, a disgusting man
has been nominated by Republicans to potentially
be the next governor of Pennsylvania. And
sadly, it is a man named Doug Mastriano,
who, if given the opportunity in 2024 to
steal Pennsylvania for the eventual Republican
presidential nominee, he would do it. There are
two choices in Pennsylvania for governor. There's
Doug Mastriano, who is a big lie promulgate
here and a guy who would do all the things
Trump wanted governors to do for him in 2020. And
then you've got Democratic nominee Josh SHAPIRO.
There's not that much to say about Josh SHAPIRO.
He's a completely standard. Milk toast. And I
don't say that in a pejorative, just he's just a
normal Democrat who wouldn't do anything crazy.
He wouldn't try to steal an election. And
that's pretty damn good right now because of
what the Republican Party has become. And now
to add on to the absurdity of Doug Mastriano,
it turns out that Doug Mastriano once donned a
Confederate uniform, Confederate uniform, while
he was in the military. And as a result, more
and more Republicans are endorsing his Democratic
opponent, Josh SHAPIRO. Business Insider reports
seven more Republican leaders endorse Democrat
Josh SHAPIRO for Pennsylvania governor, following
news of Mastriano wearing a Confederate military
uniform. Seven more Republicans have announced
their endorsement for Democrat Josh SHAPIRO one
month after nine Republicans called his Republican
opponent dogmatic. Doug Mastriano an extremist.
A photo obtained by Reuters showed Mastriano
posing in a Confederate military uniform.
This is the picture which we're putting up on the
screen for you here. And it is completely vile.
This is a picture from 2014. It was taken while
then State Senator Doug Mastriano was part of
the faculty at the U.S. Army War College. Faculty
members were permitted to pose for the photo while
dressed as historical figures, and Mastriano
chose a Confederate, a Confederate uniform,
and now is losing the support of at least a
number of Republicans. So, you know, we can talk
all day about the Confederate uniform. We can
say, well, you know, it's it is a historical
reality that there were Confederate soldiers. And
so it's not necessarily reflective of his poverty.
Right. I'm an idiot. I sound like an
idiot when I try to try to say this.
Okay. The fact that he is wearing the uniform
alone doesn't mean Doug Mastriano wishes we could
bring back the enslaving of black people. I'm not
saying that, but this is all part of a picture,
right? This is all part of the bigger
picture about Doug Mastriano and who he is.
Big lie, conspiracy theorist, unhinged number
one. Secondly, has this campaign adviser who is
overtly as anti-Semitic as anyone I've ever
heard of, sort of, you know. Right. I mean,
World War Two era German leaders said that Jews
don't even have a place in the Republican Party,
even if they're conservative. Disgusting. Right.
And then Mastriano wears a Confederate uniform.
So we're building up a picture that is based on
a number of different pillars, and they're all
disgusting, rotting pillars covered in pond
scum. So it would be great. On the one hand,
if the more moderate establishment Republicans
jumped ship from these disgusting MAGA people,
that's a good thing because we want the
MAGA people to lose. On the other hand,
if it goes too far, those very moderate
Republicans might end up running as Democrats
and it could end up moving the Democratic Party to
the right, which we also don't want. We want the
Democratic Party moving to the left. And so that's
a consideration and that's a concern as well. But
it's really important. Really important. I mean,
Pennsylvania is one of the most important states.
And, you know, I'm not saying some states don't
matter, but, you know, Wyoming, even though Liz
Cheney lost her primary, that's going to be a
Republican member of Congress. Either way, Wyoming
is not going to be the difference maker over the
next two years in the United States. On the other
hand, look at Pennsylvania. Pennsylvania is a
state on which control of the Senate could hinge,
meaning that the Oz versus Fetterman
race is extraordinarily important.
And Pennsylvania is a state on which the
2024 presidential election could hinge,
and thus having a governor in Pennsylvania
who won't try to steal the state's electors.
For the candidate that didn't win, that's an
important thing. And so that's why we need Josh
SHAPIRO to be the next governor of Pennsylvania,
not Doug Mastriano, who is just absolutely and
completely vile. So. If you're if you live in
Pennsylvania, of course, you should vote in both
of those elections. But no matter where you live,
you can phone bank and you can donate in those two
races. And they are very, very important races
are just Mastriano is disgusting. He's really
the worst of the worst of maggot politics
and hopefully we can defeat him in November
and then he just goes away. Today is the
David Pakman show member Town Hall. The day
has finally come Wednesday, August 31st, unless
you're listening to this on a different day.
Wednesday, August 31st is today at 6 p.m.
Eastern Time, 3 p.m. Pacific. We will be doing a
member town hall. It will be broadcast for all
to see on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. But for
this particular one, the participants will be our
members at join Pacman dot com and you can sign up
right up until the start of the town hall at join
Packman dot com so that you can participate today.